Taylor's 34 years old every single
boyfriend it's his [__] machine that
she runs them through a huge Calamity
they also get famous for good for bad
this thing with uh her current boyfriend
she just broke up with
Matt Healey who's I guess a lead singer
of this uh band
1975 and uh he's also a fan of like
comedy podcasts I think he was on um
and uh he had some jokes I guess about
ice spice okay
all of a sudden ice comes out on
Taylor's tour now granted she is a huge
artist right now so that could have been
already planned but it could have been a
PR move to protect she comes out on
Taylor's tour and then a couple days
later Taylor breaks up with yeah the
1975 guy
right yeah
coincidence
yeah when you put it like that it don't
seem like it I wonder if she even knows
I wonder if Taylor's just in this like
narcissism spin cycle where it's like
whatever feeds the Beast whatever is
necessary to feed the beast she will eat
and the Beast is building up and
becoming the most successful artist in
history and she's arguably there one of
them yeah right but I wonder if she can
even tell the difference like in the
same way that like Kardashians dating
people it's like I do like him but do I
like him I don't know but I like the
attention that I get from liking him and
dating him yeah and maybe that's the
same feeling of me actually liking
someone's personality and enjoying their
company and when you're feeling good
you're not distinguishing what's making
you feel good exactly that's a lot of
analysis to say what's making me do I
really like this person do I like the
attention like what is it that's
actually certain it's hard to discern
what it is especially if you have like a
tumultuous childhood you're like you'll
yearn for the love that your parents
gave you even if it wasn't good you know
what I mean like if your parents were
like yeah explain that but if your
parents were like cold to you like for
some people they'll like yearn for like
a cold love from like other people or
from partners because that's what their
parents gave them that's what they're
supposed to learn love is and that's
what they think that it is and that's
what feels good to them so like again I
don't know what her childhood was but
like if she's looking for spectacle and
like attention through her relationships
that might have been what it felt like
with her parents or something and so she
might not even be able to discern
because she's like oh yeah this is what
my whole life has been this is what
childhood is this is
I actually I think she might have gotten
into the pattern of
using her dating life as a creative
inspiration yeah so it's like at this
point we've seen it happen so many times
where it's like okay what's my new Muse
dude that is so [__] true you hear
about this a lot of time in like fashion
with like designers having a muse right
there's a model that they really like a
singer a person Kanye right like so
interesting Muses yeah and um but
basically he uh yeah that's really
interesting you get to a certain level
of success and she is at the top of it
right
I'm sure you guys may have even felt
like we get a little bit more
comfortable there's less things
irritating you like when we're in Miami
nothing was irritating me it was hard to
write jokes like life was just so good I
was just enjoying everything
imagine that times a million when you're
Taylor Swift you're [__] almost at a
B you can do whatever you want you know
the biggest tour in the world what is
the motivation to write what is the
motivation to sing what is the
motivation to pour your heart out maybe
that only comes in the form of these
relationships and heartache so she's
seeking it out to fill the Beast that it
has created machine and maybe she didn't
even notice to give her some credit
because I do think she does it
intentionally but maybe it just happens
like your brain associates oh I date a
guy I break up with a guy I get more
famous it's all just good feelings like
the breakup I just write a song about it
everybody thinks I'm great and they're
shitty and I get more famous and more
love and more isolation and to defend
her I would say like
why can't she talk about her
relationships why can't she talk about
her experiences we're Comics like we we
would talk about the things that go on
in our life 100 we're on a podcast
talking about dating talking about our
wives talking about these things so it's
not weird that she doesn't but just
seeking out experiences and people in
order to do it that's where do you know
I would also love the Taylor Swift song
that's like I [__] up too
that song hey I made some mistakes too
yeah a couple songs like that oh she
does I'm the problem it's me okay Swifty
yeah
yeah I'm not familiar enough with the
music I mean I know that obviously the
bangers but I don't know the music
enough to like say if she's completely
self-aware about what's going on I also
think it's very easy to criticize the
people who are most successful so I want
to make sure we're being fair oh she's
for talent wise it's insane she's
unbelievable
amazing apparently everybody who's gone
to it has said it's incredible like
she's putting on a concert for hours in
these stadiums and 40 songs [__] nuts
yeah so I just want to give one take so
uh the show the idol how the girl is
like your theory she might be a
narcissist and that's why
she gets with these bad boys to push
back against the type to Rebel yeah I
think it could also possibly be you know
how like people in authoritative roles
they sometimes have like Kinks that they
want to be like shamed like they'll go
to dominatrix or some [__] like that and
so I think somebody like Leo and Wolf of
Wall Street yeah so somebody in that
road like they have all these yes people
around them all these people there are
just nice no yeah it's just having one
person that could be like tell me no one
in a while
so she she's in such a power position
yeah that the lack of control or lack of
power is what would turn her on yeah
because think about that like she choked
herself so it's like she's only getting
off by like having to cut off oxygen to
her body just so she can get off yeah
and then he does he does this very
similar thing to it oh wow nobody in her
life would ever do something like that
to him right yeah it might be what they
yo dude that's awful that's why I also
think specifically
young Stars it's so difficult because
they don't have the opportunity to build
real friendships before they're famous
because if you can build real
friendships before you're famous or on
the way up you can have a level of
honesty with people if you're famous at
14 you have friends but nobody even
knows what's going on at 14 years old
you don't even know if you like each
other you just both like the fact that
you make jokes about the teacher in math
class there's not a lot of real
connective tissue there
so you don't have the opportunity to
build those real friends and then all
the friends that you make in your early
adult years
you're like do these people only like me
because I'm successful yeah exactly oh
man man you don't even know who you are
really 100 we all thought we knew who we
were at 19 20 21 being a [__]
question and we didn't have people
telling us who we are at 19. yeah we had
the opportunity to find it we just
didn't yeah that you got your publicist
telling you you're this person you've
got your agent telling you you're this
person also all your friends are also
famous
like and when you're 18 and not famous
and you say some dumb [__] your friends
could be like shut the [__] up yeah they
will yeah there they're gonna be like oh
yeah yeah that's good that's good yeah
keep scared keep doing that and
everybody's singularly focused on this
one thing and each person is almost like
a lily pad on your way there you know so
it's like uh you don't know if that's a
true friendship or if it's being around
you is clout
yeah yeah the insecurity you must feel I
understand why a lot of them probably
abuse drugs it's just like to ease that
anxiety yeah every interaction you're
anxious everything you tell somebody
you're like oh my God are they going to
tell that to TMZ imagine how many times
you get your heart broken by the people
you trust the most like then you just
have no trust for anybody
that's also probably why it's hard to
make these relationships work yeah
because just from you don't trust
anybody like how do you everything seems
transactional everybody seems like they
want something from me why would I trust
you to be different yeah just because
you're famous too no your narcissist is
just like me you're probably getting
some out of this just like me
it's tough dude